il ya un chroniqueur qui a été
interviewé par le magazine ici paris
c'est un magazine qui se trouve à paris
c'est juste ici et et il a fait une
petite annonce concernant sa
participation à des pmp la saison
prochaine c'est bernard montiel
montbernard d'amour que j'aime bernard
montiel bernard montciel bernard mon
ange gardien
bernard pontneau pour attaquer les
autres je te montrerai sic et mon pote
berne bernard montiel donc qui reste la
saison prochaine avec nous dans touche
pas à mon poste à montbert nous c'était
bernard montiel en direct du cap ferret
bien entendu merci pour ce témoignage je
salue bernard pose la question à savoir
si les yeux qu'on suivait les aventures
avec vous et je dis évidemment eu la
chance de parler à l'été et on a envie
d'aller évidemment de bons mois bah
bravo voilà merci bernard d'avoir été
avec nous qu'on entend très mal bernard
merci bernard d'avoir été là je te fais
de gros bisous montbard autant comme
c'est balmont jury donc je suis très
content que tu sois avec fulham et
possède et bien sûr tu seras toujours
partie de l'équipe
tu es notre famille on est à famille et
jeu sera toujours là voilà on t'aime il
est magnifique magnifique il est pas
beau que mou il est magnifique oui jean
michel maire je croyais qu'on devait
donner que des bonnes nouvelles pour
divertir les gens eh ben je me donne une
dans un instant vous verrez jamais sera
dans tpm paix le samedi et je vous
arrête un instant souhaité calmer fera
du lundi au vendredi merci voilà